bonsoir françois pour les mathis merci
d'être avec nous la cour des comptes qui
a qualifié d' agences d'inefficace dans
ses missions d'incompétente les mots
sont durs 1 tout d'abord françois cette
victoire sur les institutions
européennes
cela dit une chose de manière très
évidente c'est que cette agence a été
créé un peu dans la précipitation avec à
cause de la pression migratoire
mais cette agence elle a grandi trop
vite elle n'était pas mûre
elle n'avait pas les capacités réelles
pour effectuer sa mission pourquoi et
bien tout simplement parce que l'europe
n'est pas un pays
l'europe est un ensemble de 27 pays or
on demande à l' agence de contrôle tenu
par le problème de l'émigration qui est
un énorme problème mais aussi la
criminalité transfrontalière
on sait très bien les crimes n'ont pas
de frontières les criminels n'ont pas de
frontières et la pression migratoire
elle est partout elle est seule non
seulement à l'est mais elle est aussi à
l'ouest elle est à la fois sur le
domaine maritime
elle est à la fois sur le domaine
terrestre donc cessons des tâches très
complexes pour lesquels les
fonctionnaires qui je le rappelle sont
des fonctionnaires détachés de leurs
administrations nationales pour
lesquelles ces fonctionnaires n'ont pas
été véritablement préparé dans des
délais corrects
donc on efface effectivement à une crise
de croissance d'une vraie crise de
croissance l'europe n'étant pas un pays
on a une agence on a finalement des
gardes-frontières et garde-côtes qui
devrait faire partie d'un ensemble qui
est fédéral or l'europe n'est pas
fédéral c'est là que réside le principal
malaise finalement de cette agence qui
actuellement effectivement n'a pas des
moyens chi pas forcément les moyens
matériels mais n'a pas les moyens en
véritable coopération des états pour
effectuer ses missions
et il ya surtout une à domaine dans
lequel effectivement le problème est
grave c'est qu'il ya actuellement un
manque évident de collaboration des 27
pays membres pour partager leurs données
comment une agence de gardes-frontières
garde-côtes peut-elle fonctionner
normalement
si on ne partage pas ces données or
c'est bien ce qui se passe et c'est là
véritablement à des problèmes majeurs de
cette croissance qui est encore très
défaillante
agence frontex ça veut dire que cette
agence malgré ses moyens quand même
colossaux on en reparlera elle doit
gérer un problème qui est plus grand
qu'elle si j'ose dire qu'ils qui est
ingérable
à ce niveau là en tout cas de l'europe
en théorie il pourrait être gérable à
condition que les états membres qui
participent à cette agence rotex accepte
finalement de véritablement partager
leurs moyens mais pas seulement leurs
moyens humains mais leurs moyens en
matière d'information une information à
quelque chose d'essentiel pour
l'efficacité de frontex frontex
c'est finalement une agence dont les
fonctionnaires enregistre régulièrement
aux frontières notamment les demandeurs
d'asile pour prendre exactement leur
identité et ses 17 aussi on lui a
demandé
c'est une surcharge de travail
effectivement de s'attaquer à la
criminalité organisée à la criminalité
transfrontière et on sait très bien les
criminels internationaux ne connaissent
pas les frontières
or visiblement c'est une tâche qui
dépassaient les capacités actuelles de
frontex est donc là c'est un véritable
problème
il y a une véritable question à se poser
est ce que il faut faire un bond en
avant en matière c'est un domaine
régalien je le sais bien
mais dans ce domaine si les européens
considèrent que les problèmes
d'immigration et les problèmes de
criminalité sont essentiels ce qui
apparaît d'ailleurs dans les sondages et
bien dans ce cas là il faut en tirer les
conséquences et les conséquences
effectivement de faire un saut dans la
délégation de poules oies vers des
pouvoirs d'une d'une agence qui
actuellement ne les a pas clairement le
rapport pointe un frontex ne fera pas
encore aux états membres un soutien
suffisant dans la gestion des frontières
extérieures de lieux ça veut dire
qu'actuellement les frontières
européennes ne sont pas si bien protégé
effectivement elles ne sont pas toujours
bien protégés et surtout je compte les
différents pays européens ont des
attitudes différentes que ce soit au
niveau de l'immigration que ce soit au
niveau de la gestion le frontier un pays
par exemple comme la hongrie ne
participe pas vraiment au programme
frontex dans la mesure où il considère
que d'une façon il
ne se sent pas solidaires de l'action
européenne en matière d'immigration et
donc dès le moment où les pays entre eux
ne s'accorde pas sur un minimum de
règles et surtout de partage
d'informations effectivement on s'expose
à cette question autre exemple récent
celui du maroc où finalement l'union
européenne presse l'espagne
effectivement de mettre en oeuvre les
moyens de l'agencé frontex pour
effectivement gérer cette question de
pression marocaine où les banques fait
pression effectivement avec ces émigrés
qui arrive à cieutat notamment et bien
là aussi l'espagne hésite finalement à
transférer à l' agence frontex tous les
moyens qui lui sera nécessaire dans la
mesure où l'espagne a peur finalement
qu'un certain nombre de questions
relèvent de sa de sa souveraineté et ne
peut être partagée
voilà un des sujets qui posent un
véritable problème de fonctionnement qui
montera à vous entendre en tout cas une
fois de plus le manque d'unité qui règne
au sein des pays de l'union européenne
il n'empêche un ils se sont accordés sur
une chose c'est le budget de cette
agence qui est quand même passé de 19
millions en 2006 à 900 millions - par an
entre 2021 et 2027 ça veut dire quand
même qu'on veut y mettre les moyens
avec le succès voilà très mitigé qu'on
est en train de décrire que commencer et
c'est possible autant de gâchis d'argent
alors que souvent les caisses d etat
sont vides mais s'ils devront paradoxe
c'est le grand paradoxe parce que
pratiquement toute la population tous
les européens dans leur ensemble
souhaitent effectivement avoir davantage
de moyens aux frontières de l'union
européenne pour se protéger tout le
monde le pendage mais en même temps
aujourd'hui en particulier dans tous les
pays européens on clame l'importance de
garder sa souveraineté dans un certain
nombre de domaines il ya des choses qui
ne sont pas compatibles on peut pas
avoir le beurre et l'argent du beurre
dès le moment où on considère qu'il n'ya
une action collective à mener pour le
contrôle de l'immigration pour le
contrôle de la grande criminalité et
qu'il faut mettre dans ce cas là des
moyens en commun non seulement des mois
il s'agit pas seulement d'argent mais
les moyens aussi de la formation
j'insiste sur le fait de la formation
les systèmes de chaque pays sont jaloux
finalement de leurs prérogatives
effectivement hésitent à partager leurs
informations
on ne peut pas continuer éternellement
comme ça si on veut si on veut une
véritable agence n'a pas de frontières
garde-côtes
comme il existe par exemple aux états
unis ben pour en rendre les moyens et
ses moyens actuellement suppose
effectivement un bon dans l'abandon de
souveraineté et c'est que c'est là la
difficulté
merci beaucoup françois problématise
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre analyse